[Music]
bitcoin mining is now actually
understood to be something which is a
component of the energy grid because in
a sense just like when you say a
document it's both a paper document and
it's a digital thing right like we use
the term interchangeably now so in a
sense
bitcoin mining is now like a money
battery because on the power grid you
can't store power that easily you have
to sort of instantaneously generate it
as being consumed and every flick of a
light switch and so on to serve in this
model of this
gaussian where uh you don't all these
small events you can't predict whether
you're going to flick the light switch
on or not but you can have sort of
demand prediction
and it kind of goes up and down you
generate the power in proportion to that
the problem is that
if you've got sources of power that are
themselves variable like renewables for
example is the sun shining or not is it
wind blowing or not right now you've got
volatility on both sides and it's hard
to to match that up and um
bitcoin mining actually comes in there
because it's a load that you can put
basically in any location and dial it
all the way up and rather than trying to
store
that energy in a battery okay you quote
store it as money
by mining bitcoin and depending on the
economics it may be
better to do that
and then with that
btc buy energy later
then to actually store it in a
conventional battery okay that's super
that's super interesting super
interesting so this is an important
thing that is happening now actually
ted cruz of all people actually gave a
talk on this so it's starting to filter
out into
politicians
wait ted cruz gave a talk on this
subject yes just a few weeks ago wow
that's in that's that's unexpected all
right yeah well so that's the thing is
this is becoming a big thing within
natural gas and so on because the
flaring problem of having this you know
it looks like this dystopian blast of
flame into the air when you have uh like
stranded gas uh that that gets
addressed with this
so was he speaking with within the
confines of the state of texas or was it
more broadly applied it's much more
broadly applied this is something which
is you know i'm not an expert in this
area okay but uh google like bitcoin
mining oil and gas
and you will be able to read about this
right but it's also something it's not
just oil and gas it's also renewables
essentially
your renewable energy source
bitcoin mining increases the
profitability of it
because there is always demand for the
renewable energy you're generating
say that one more time please
i mean i'll be more precise so
your renewable energy source
like especially if it's volatile like
solar power or wind wind
now there's always
a way to make money from it even if
there isn't demand on the grid because
it's volatile for example the sun may be
shining
but nobody's turning on their appliances
or the wind may be blowing and nobody's
actually
consuming the power but you can use that
to mine bitcoin
yeah that's uh that's very interesting
you